هذا ما يبدو عليه القتال في قطاع
غزه انفاق وقذائف محليه
الصنع في مواجهه دبابات واليات عسكريه
محصنه تلك قوات بريه لا تتقدم دون مظله
تغطيها بها القوات
[موسيقى]
الجويه من السابع من اكتوبر وحتتى بدء
التوغل البري في الساب من اكتوبر 20 يوما
من نار تصبها الطائرات الاسرائيليه من
السماء على ارض قطاع
غزه هكذا كان سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي يسحق
ولا يزال كل حياه على الارض تمهيدا لتقدم
القوات البريه لكن كل ذلك لم يكن يتحقق
دون قدرات استخباراتيه فائقه تملا
السماء اذا بعيدا عن الطائرات المحمله
باطنان المتفجرات ثمت عيون اسرائيليه في
السماء توجه تلك القنابل كما توجه القوات
على الارض فاي امكانيات استخباراتيه جويه
اسرائيليه تواجهها المقاومه في قطاع غزه
في هذا التحقيق تتبعنا فقط الطائرات التي
تستخدمها اسرائيل في التجسس على المقاومه
وفق النتائج التي وصلنا اليها فان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يستخدم 14 نوعا من الطائرات
الاستخباراتيه تنقسم هذه الطائرات الى
نوعين اساسيين الطائرات الماهوله بالافراد
والطائرات غير الماهوله بالافراد اما
الطائرات الماهوله بالافراد فتتكون من سته
انواع رئيسيه تمثل هذه الانواع الطيران
الاستراتيجيه في المعركه حيث يشرف على
اداره المعارك على الارض بشكل كبير جدا
لابعد التفاصيل من حيث حركه القوات البريه
ومناوراتها تقدما وتراجعا وتمركز كما يصمم
الاحزمه الناريه وحقول الرمايه المدفعيه
ويستهدف المنازل وينفذ المجازر كما انه
يحرك ويشرف على رمايات وضربات الطيران
الحربي هكذا تتم قياده العمليات البريه
والجويه من خلال هذا النوع الطيران
الماهول بالافراد
في هذا التحقيق حصلت الجزيره على صور
لابرز الطائرات الماهوله التي تحلق في
سماء غزه سته انواع من الطائرات الماهوله
بالافراد جميعها امريكيه الصنع تحمل هذه
الطائرات الجنود والمظليين كما تحمل اجهزه
مراقبه واستشعار يحلق على ارتفاع يتراوح
بين 7000 الى 15 الف متر عن سطح
الارض تظهر هذه اللقطات الحصريه للجزيره
تحليق هذه الطائره في سماء القطاع وهي من
نوع سي 130 جي سوبر هركو تستخدم لنقل
العتاد والجنود ومهام اعاده التزود
بالوقود في الجو للطائرات تحمل على متنها
ما بين 90 و130 جنديا وتمتلك اسرائيل اربع
طائرات منها تشبهها الى حد ما طائره بوينج
707 لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي منها نموذجان
الاول يسمى رعيم ويستخدم في مهام نقل
الجنود والعتاد والثاني يسمى سكني ويستخدم
في مهام اعاده التزوج بالوقود للطائرات
المقاتله هذا بالاضافه الى طائرات سيسنا
كرافان 208 وطائره نشون المطوره من طائره
جلف ستريم وطائره كوكيا التي تعتبر من
اشهر طائرات التجسس في العالم واكثرها
انتشارا كما يوجد خمسه نماذج من طائره دزو
فيت التي يمتلك الجيش الاسرائيلي 22 طائره
منها وتستخدم في مهام الاستطلاع وجمع
المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه قد تمكنا في هذا التحقيق من
رصد الطائرات غير الماهوله بالافراد التي
يستخدمها الجيش الاسرائيلي في حربه على
قطاع غزه وفق النتائج فان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يستخدم ثمانيه انواع من هذه
الطائرات التي تختلف في مميزاتها ومهام
لكنها تجتمع في قدراتها التكنولوجيه
الهائله على الرصد والتتبع وبعضها مزود
بانظمه لاطلاق الرصاصي او الصواريخ
الصغيره ويمكن تصنيفها الى ثلاثه انواع
رئيسيه بحسب حجمها التي تطير على ارتفاعات
عاليه وال الحوامات متوسطه الحجم
والمسيرات
[تصفيق]
الصغيره ابرز الطائرات غير الماهوله التي
تحلق على ارتفاعات عاليه هي من عائلتي
هيرون وهرمز الاستراتيجيتين عده نماذج من
طائره هيرون تي بي القادره على انجاز
المهام الدوريه السريه وبامكانها جمع
المعلومات خلال الليل والنهار كما لها
قدرات متقدمه في التنسيق بين المحطات
الارضيه ومحطات الفيديو التي يتم التحكم
بها عن بعد وتبادل المعلومات هذا بالاضافه
الى طائره هيرمز بالنموذج 900
و450 صنفت هيرمز 900 في السنوات الاخيره
على انها من افضل الطائرات بدون طيار على
مستوى العالم شكلت قفزه في قدراتها
التكنولوجيه من خلال حمل مجموعه واسعه جدا
من اجهزه الاستشعار هذا بالاضافه الى
قدرتها على حمل ما يصل الى اربعه صواريخ
جو ارض وصواريخ جو جو وقنبل التين موجهت
بالليزر تعمل هيرمز فوق البحر والبر
ومزوده برادار يغذي الغواصات بالمعلومات
النموذج الشقيق هو هيرمز 450 التي تحمل
كاميرا تلفزيونيه نهاريه وكاميرا تصوير
حراريه للاستطلاع الليلي كما يمكنها
مراقبه التقلبات
الجويه النوع الثاني من الطائرات غير
الماهوله يتمثل في الحوامات وهي طائرات
متوسطه الحجم تحلق على ارتفاعات منخفضه
نسبيا يمكن حصر هذه الطائرات وفق ال نتائج
في هذا التحقيق الى عائلتين اساسيتين هما
اوربيت سكايلارك تضم عائله اور بيتر خمسه
نماذج مقسمه الى نوعين بحسب الوظيفه منها
ما هو انتحاري ومنها ما هو
استخباراتي هذه صور حصريه للجزيره تظهر
اور بيتر التي تعتبر عنوان التعاون
العسكري بين الهند واسرائيل تعمل الطائره
المسيره بانواعها على تنفيذ الاغتيالات اذ
يمكنها رصد الهدف عبر بصمه الصوت شقيقتها
في مثل هذه المهام العائله الثانيه من هذا
النوع وهي طائرات سكاي لارك ذات السته
نماذج التي صممت خصيصا للعمليات التكتيكيه
واستخبارات ميدان المعركه كما لديها قدره
عاليه على المراقبه وتحديد الاهداف والبث
المباشر تستعملها كتائب المشاه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي للمهام الاستخباراتيه وجمع
المعلومات كما تستعملها قوات المدفعيه
لرصد الاهداف ومتابعتها ثم نوع اخر رصد في
سماء قطاع غزه خلال هذه الحرب بعد البحث
وجدنا ان هذه الطائره هي من نوع وندر بي
اسرائيليه الصنع التي دخلت الخدمه عام
2019 اثناء البحث وجدنا ان دوله اوروبيه
لم يكشف عنها قدمت طلبا لشراء 150 طائره
من هذا
النوع النوع الثالث من الطائرات غير
الماهوله التي رصدناها في هذا التحقيق فهي
الاصغر حجما لكنها الاكثر خطوره او خطيره
للغايه يمكن القول ان هذه المسيرات هي
طائرات قاتله صغيره ابرزها مافيك بانواعها
وماتس 600 واير
كابتر تستخدم مافيك بنموذج مافيك اين وبرو
للتصوير بدرجه اساسيه تعتبر من اصغر
الحوامات في العالم واكثرها قوه وتتضمن
نظام استشعار متقدما ومساحه تخزين كبيره
يمكن تثبيت مكبر صوت على الطائره يوفر
اتصالا فعالا بين الفرق الارضيه اثناء ح
الطوارئ واضاءه كاشفه لتعزيز الرؤيه في
المناطق ذات الاضاءه المنخفضه للمساعده في
تحديد مكان الشخص المفقود اما طائره ماترس
600 فهي متعدده الاستخدامات يمكنها ان
تحمل رشاشا واجهزه التجسس وقنابل وكاميرات
رصدت ماتر 600 فوق التجمعات السكنيه بشكل
يومي اثناء الحرب يشبهها الى حد ما طائره
اير كابتر وهي حوامه عموديه مجنحه تستخدم
في مها هام الاستطلاع كما يمكنها تنفيذ
عمليات انتحاريه هكذا كان هذا النوع من
اخطر الطائرات الاستخباراتيه في هذه الحرب
اذ انها مزوده بتكنولوجيا متقدمه للغايه
على راسها تتبع بصمه الصوت ونفذت كثيرا من
عمليات الاغتيال لمقاتلين ومواطنين
فلسطينيين اثناء هذه الحرب خطورتها تكمن
في صغر حجمها وقدرتها على الدخول بين
الازقه وبعضها تمكن من الدخول الى منازل
الفلسطينيين وتنفيذ مهامها
[موسيقى]
القاتله تمكنت المقاومه الفلسطينيه خلال
هذه الحرب من اسقاط عدد كبير من هذه
المسيرات القاتله فكان من ابرز ما سيطرت
عليه المقاومه من طرازي سكايلارك واير
كبتر القلتين السيطره على طائره سكك
التابعه للواء
درعات هكذا يحلق الجيش الاسرائيلي الى
اعالي السماء ليبتعد قدر الامكان عن
المواجهه المباشره لهذه الحرب طائرات تنقل
الجنود والعتاد واخرى تلاحق وتراقب
وتستشعر وصغيره تقتل بالصمت كل هذه
التكنولوجيا المتطوره المحليه والمستورده
تتزاحم في سماء قطاع غزه وتبحث عن انتصار
على المقاومه الفلسطينيه على ارض القطع
قطاع مساحته لا تتجاوز 360 كيلومترا مربعا
حفرت فيه المقاومه الفلسطينيه الانفاق
وصنعت العبوات والقذائف لمواجهه الاحتلال
يمكن القول ان هذه الحرب هي حرب بين
الهروب الى السماء والمسافه
الصفر